given that the definite integral from
negative 1 to 3 of f of x dx is equal to
negative 2
and the definite integral from negative
1 to 3 of g of x dx is equal to 5
what is the definite integral from
negative 1 to 3 of three f of x minus
two g of x dx
all right so to think about this what we
could use is some of our integration
properties and so the first thing that i
would want to do is we could split this
up into two integrals we know that
the and this is true of definite or
indefinite integrals that the integral
of f of x
the integral of f of x plus or minus g
of x
dx
is going to be equal to the integral
of f of x
dx
plus or minus the integral of g of x
dx if this is a plus this is going to be
a plus if this is a minus this is going
to be a minus so we could split this up
in the same way so this is going to be
equal to the definite integral from
negative 1
to 3
of 3
f of x
dx
minus the integral from negative 1 to 3
of 2
g of x
dx notice all i did is i split it up
taking the the integral of the
difference of these functions is the
same thing as taking the difference of
the integrals of those functions now the
next thing we can do is we can take the
scalars we're multiplying the functions
on the inside by these numbers 3 and 2
and we can take those outside of the
integral and that comes straight out of
the property that if i'm taking the
integral of some constant times f of x
dx that is equal to the constant times
the integral of f of x
dx and so i can rewrite this as
so
let's see i can rewrite this first
integral as 3 times the definite
integral from negative 1
to
of f of x
dx
minus 2
times the definite integral from
negative 1 to 3
of g of x actually let me do the second
one in a different color
minus
so this is going to be in magenta minus
2 times the integral from negative 1 to
3 of g of x
dx
and so what is this going to be equal to
well they tell us
they tell us what this thing is here
that i'm that i'm underlying in orange
the integral from negative one to three
of f of x d of dx they tell us that that
is equal to negative two so that thing
is negative two
and likewise
this thing right over here the definite
integral from negative 1 to 3 of g of x
dx they give it right over here it's
equal to 5. so that's equal to 5. and so
the whole thing
is going to be 3 times negative 2
which is equal to
negative
6 minus 2 times 5 minus 10 which is
equal to negative 16. and we're done